[Music]
first off a broader view of mobile and
its opportunities for you to reach and
impact your customers and your prospects
secondly
through this section you'll have a leg
up on other marketers who frankly have
been slow or unwilling to adapt in
changing times
and third i see an up an opportunity for
you to have new career possibilities
with your newfound knowledge of mobile
marketing and the morphing consumer
now i know that you're here for a reason
because you know that the mobile phone
has changed the way we live and conduct
marketing
but we're not just talking about any
device
we're talking about the most personal
one the mobile device
and we as brand marketers want in on the
action
will consumers really let us in
or to say it another way if two is
company does three necessarily create a
crowd
or could we instead make it easier for
the mobile user by providing value
maybe in the form of just the right
offer or information at just the
opportune moment
now even if a consumer gives us an
opening to their mobile lives
how are we as brands supposed to operate
with baby steps
or maybe by taking some sort of
permission as a license to put up our
feet on their furniture and stay all
night
and what about these ever increasing
consumer expectations
for gosh sakes i've never ever had a
meatball sandwich from your quick
service restaurant
but you mr or mrs marketer
know or should know from my purchase
history that my diet is vegetarian so
why am i still getting those meatball
sandwich ads
and what about the customer journey
if i'm looking at an armani tie tonight
online should you target me tomorrow
when i'm near or in a nordstrom
or is that personal or is something
that's just plain creepy
and what about the ever increasing
self-sufficient mobile shopper pushing
to examine the very definition of
customer service
so we're here to talk about what's the
role of today's marketer
and can we be replaced by machines
but first i'd like to give you a level
set
more people on earth have a mobile phone
than a toothbrush or a toilet
wireless penetration in the united
states alone exceeds a hundred percent
meaning that there's more than one
mobile phone for every person from coast
to coast
the cell phone has changed the way we
communicate or don't communicate
buy
share
deposit a check engage our health among
tens of other things that will never be
the same
in developing countries the mobile phone
is literally a lifeline leading to
cleaner water
more diagnosis and treatment of disease
and banking for the unbanked
so this all means what
as marketers if we fail to adapt to the
upheaval our customers and prospects
will be someone else's customers and
prospects i here to say the early
scorecard on our efforts largely largely
shows that we're behind
now why do i say that
the trouble is that what comes to the
expectations the mobile user they're
sophisticated and deserve more credit
than we give them
and those who carry these devices are
picking sides
so let's get working on meeting and
beating those expectations
now mobile also is a key ingredient it
benefits other digital marketing and
traditional media
and with mobile what we need to do is
follow the money and follow the eyeballs
so let's define what mobile marketing is
i always defer to the mobile marketing
association's definition of mobile
marketing
now mobile marketing is a set of
practices that enables organizations to
communicate with their audience in an
interactive and relevant manner through
any mobile device or network
now that sounds like it came right out
of academia so let me break it down a
little bit for you the key words in that
phrase are interactive and relevant
now first off interactive
we know that mobile users have their
phone
next to them nearly 24 hours a day they
use their phone in multitasking while
they're watching television while
they're on their computer they're
checking facebook they're responding to
a text message so there is an
interactivity that we've never seen
pre-mobile uh era
also the second word that's critically
important is the word relevant
nothing as i mentioned earlier is more
personal than a mobile device
and my mobile device while the same
model as my wife's mobile device is
entirely different
i have different interests i have
different apps i go to different sites
and what marketers need to do is to
identify and respond to those individual
mobile needs so we can provide personal
and relevant and contextual experiences
now the mobile marketing association
further says mobile marketing includes
activities institutions processes
industry players standards advertising
and media direct response promotions
relationship management crm
customer services loyalty social
marketing and all facets of marketing
now as we're about guy we want to say 10
to 12 years into really the the mobile
marketing era
we are seeing some significant uh
mileposts or mild uh
changes when it comes to what's
happening out there we're seeing the
most sophisticated brands
get way beyond having just mobile
departments or having direct departments
what they're doing is they're knocking
down walls and everybody is mobile as
the googles of the world and the lowe's
home improvement companies in coca-cola
the job of mobile is everybody's job
now mobile is a key ingredient how do
you measure it uh and there are two
different ways to engage mobile users
there's the poll where a user responds
to a call to action
that might be on a marketing a piece of
marketing material it might be a push
message that you send to them um or a a
pull pull is really how a consumer is
going to take his or her his or her own
decision making process and saying okay
i want to interact with a brand now this
is opposed to a push message or a push
notification is one execution of that
where a marketer sends out information
to somebody and as we walk through this
course we'll talk about how to use
things like push notifications
do you need permission or don't you need
permission do people need to opt in and
so forth
now mobile is a key ingredient there are
three functions of mobile marketing i
believe that there are three
key things that we can do we can delight
mobile users
we can engage with mobile users and the
most important thing is that we can sell
now the first three words of my book
mobilized marketing had the word sell
more beer
and they told the story of the head of
digital at miller coors who has the same
job that everybody in his position had
for the last 157 years before him he
needs to sell more stuff
so my position is that the job of the
marketer has remained entirely constant
even in this upheaval of mobile
marketing
the what is the same we need still need
to sell stuff
it's that how that's changed
so mobile marketing is permission based
targeting
where a user responds to a call to
actions now these call to actions
when i first started in mobile back in
around 2007 2006 i had heard about a
campaign where a
candy bar manufacturer had asked
consumers to respond to something on the
packaging now the problem was that the
call to action was inside the candy bar
wrapper
and
i don't know if you're like me i assume
that you are when we want that that when
we're that hungry that we want that
candy bar we're not going to open up the
wrapper rather gingerly we're not going
to look inside and see if the uh if the
marketer or the maker of the candy is
going to ask us for do to do something
so we're now way more sophisticated
calls to actions are more widespread
they're looked for in a lot of cases by
mobile users and they're responded to
and and through the course of uh our
teaching now what mobile marketing isn't
it's not a license to spam
we'll talk about the rules and
regulations that are
quite prevalent globally that were set
up by organizations like the mobile
marketing association and then some
guidelines by the iab
and other groups
but the rules and regulations have been
established by the carriers by ctia
by the the global mobile organizations
and other marketers there are as i
mentioned some uh some
differences uh region to region and
country to country and we're going to
devote a whole section to those so
you'll be up to speed on them
now mobile marketing and mobile
advertising are not interchangeable
and just like pre-mobile
think of advertising as being a subset
of marketing
now i like to think of it is that
advertising is a single contact
where marketing is an ongoing
relationship
now oftentimes these work together and
the savvy marketers might use
advertising as the door opener
and then marketing techniques the
ability to engage with folks and ask
people in a lot of cases for permission
to create this ongoing relationship
now as i mentioned mobile marketing
provides several opportunities
we can sell product
we can engage
and when we talk about apps in this
course we'll talk about
the importance not only of getting
people to
download an app or acquisition but we'll
talk about the
ever more important function of
engagement and how do we do that
also mobile marketing is a great
place or great way to inform you might
tell folks that
there's a sale going on in your store or
you might inform them that they need to
get to uh to the polls if you're a
candidate uh you might inform them of
of where
people are
gathering if you're having a concert and
what time to get there and things like
that
and then also mobile marketing gives you
an opportunity to build brand loyalty
and as i mentioned and also wrote about
extensively in my second book called the
art of mobile persuasion
we have the opportunity to build brand
loyalty
and we also conversely have the
opportunity to really blow it
by providing bad experiences the
statistics show that the great majority
of mobile users will leave and never
come back
but conversely those of us who are smart
have the opportunity to build brand
loyalty
and really have a customer for the
foreseeable future and hopefully for
life now mobile mobile has a key role in
the marketing mix
there was a time when we were fighting
for a seat at the table there are still
some lagging
organizations that that have that same
environment now
but mobile really has earned this place
in the mix because of its demonstrated
roi
it's made passive activities interactive
it's made existing investments more
effective and more measurable
and mobile has some really key
strengths and key differentiators and
these include the opportunity to
incorporate time
location
context and interest like we never have
before
and to create these relevant and
personal experiences
and to go where the mobile user is which
more and more is on a mobile device
now let's talk about specifically
how a mobile phone
has given a us the opportunity to turn
passive activities into in into
interactive ones
well one example is television
television has become interactive with
mobile
we've seen voting uh that became uh very
popular uh in the us and then actually
globally with american idol and shows
like that where people were able to use
their phone to vote for their favorite
contestant
we're seeing uh
great examples of the opportunity to
purchase so there are shows that might
show
some
new product or new fashion and giving a
mobile user the chance to go right on
their phone and purchase
and then we're seeing uh some great
examples of opportunities to learn more
now
a lot of times the story can't be told
sufficiently in a 30-second commercial
so what the smart mobile marketers are
doing or that the marketers in general
are doing
are driving mobile users to their phones
to learn more maybe to see an automobile
on the road
maybe to personalize the experience so
they can see what they might look like
behind the wheel
look at various colors and things like
that
also retail shopping has become
interactive with mobile
as we'll talk about a lot i'm sure in
this course
uh you can do several things in uh in
the retail environment that you couldn't
do before
we'll talk about macy's and it's
backstage pass program which provides
a variety of ways for a mobile user to
interact with uh with the store and with
its call to actions and these include
things like texting in for a link
scanning a qr code driving people to a
mobile website
and receiving a either a text message or
a mobile mark
an mms message which is a multimedia
message and we'll explain that in a lot
of detail uh when we get into the
messaging session section of this uh
this curriculum
now also uh as i suggested mobile makes
existing efforts work harder and become
more measurable
now you can put these call to actions on
existing materials to produce leads
to measure which approaches are more
effective
and to generate real-time results now an
example of that is
what you can do is
have a platform
and have the ability to
look in a dashboard at real-time
campaigns running and what you could do
is you can determine
if you want to
change move the dials a bit is do you
want to uh an example is uh i remember
there was a campaign in times square
around uh the release of a batman dvd
and the the brand looked in uh on the
dashboard and saw how the interaction
with the street team members was going
so well that it uh extended the life of
the campaign by an additional couple of
hours and we can do that in real time
and we're we still do postmortems but
postmortems have an entirely different
and less important role in mobile i
believe because we have the ability like
never before to impact results in real
time
now we also can
make ineffective campaigns
be altered or mixed
and a
example of that is i'm familiar with a
coffee house that had done a call to
action through radio
and it did not get the desired foot
traffic um so what they did is they
recut the spot they changed the copy
they made it stronger and before the
flight was over they were able to impact
the results and get the traffic that
they were hoping for
now mobile also adds location
time and context so we're now more aware
of a consumer's needs in real time
there's technologies
we'll get into specifically around
location and uh the ability to know
where somebody is uh by uh maybe
tracking their device or having them uh
opt-in to be uh sent notifications when
they're in a particular
location
uh customers or consumers motivations
change with time and location
just think about it if somebody is in
times square at 11 in the morning they
have an entirely different mindset than
they might at 11 o'clock at night
they're likely earlier in the day
looking for food looking to find some an
activity uh to do that that might maybe
outside uh maybe take in a matinee and
then in the evening they might be
looking for the latest club or what
where their favorite band or
jazz club might be now so entirely
different motivations that you can react
to
depending on on day parts among other
things
also mobile makes our campaigns time and
location sensitive
we can
capitalize on things like even the
weather and we can say okay
if we know that
we are
trying to move
smoothies or trying to move cold drinks
we can
create a campaign that's gonna uh
gonna set to fire when uh when the
temperature hits 72 degrees for instance
now mobile and radio when i first got
into uh mobile i worked for a company
called hip cricket and we were primarily
doing campaigns with radio stations some
of the largest ones in the world uh
clear channel which is now iheart media
among others and mobile what was able to
revitalize what had become a
rather stagnant uh industry
but what mobile did is it provided a
large
customer base and the audience was
it was interacting with stations or had
the chance to interact with stations in
a way different way
so the
radio used mobile and continues to use
mobile in two different ways
first off to increase time spent
listening which in that industry is
absolutely gold to get somebody to
listen at a time when they wouldn't
normally listen to for instance uh if
they
told you that they like britney spears
you can send out an alert telling them
that britney spears will be in your
studio at three o'clock in the afternoon
and you can get them to listen in a time
they wouldn't normally listen
that increases time spent listening but
also
radio now has the chance to add mobile
calls to actions in its spots
uh thereby getting uh advertisers to
make their spots interactive and a great
example that is a car dealer getting
people to come to a car lot with a
simple 99
uh car promotion where somebody could
buy a car for 99
and by doing that hundreds of people
came to participate in the contest and
they sold 38 cars on a saturday morning
when they hadn't sold the car
in weeks and weeks and this uh this was
a campaign that cost less than a
thousand dollars
now also
as i've already mentioned a bit mobile
and television have become intertwined
it's really become a two screen
experience uh users are using their
mobile device to enhance their view
viewing experience i know that i do i i
um in many many cases now and i'm on
twitter while i'm watching something
i'm following the conversation i'm
participating in the conversation and
that's become as i mentioned quite
common
also
a tv spot can have a call to action that
can physically uh
get people to go into stores
it can create a symbiotic relationship
with the brand and build loyalty
and give the opportunity for mobile uh
users to uh to get even more valuable
information than they could in a
self-contained uh
tv spot
also we're seeing uh print having to
evolve in big ways
uh some print uh publishers are more
progressive than others and new york
times is is in that category
uh what they're doing is they're
bringing interest to an old model by
making the experience interactive more
current
and bringing even rich media content so
you can go behind the scenes
and so i'm a former reporter a newspaper
reporter and it used to be where you
know once a day you would need to
produce the news now there's a 24-hour
news cycle
and these print uh pub publishers need
to play in that
field as well so they're
constantly looking at
providing relevant information and that
goes back to what i was talking about
earlier what is important to me may not
be important to you
so folks like espn
are creating uh relevant experiences
asking asking you to make some
selections on who your favorite teams
are
and the same thing is happening in print
also mobile and online are complementing
each other we're seeing a
social media there used to be silos but
things like twitter and facebook are
seeing more activity on mobile devices
than we are seeing
on desktops
and really that has to do with life
lifestyle decisions and people not
wanting to forego their interests say in
connecting with their friends and family
just because they turned off their
phones
and then mobile also will get into has
some key
attributes that help other efforts like
search engine optimization paid search
web analytics and conversion
optimization we'll talk about the uh the
differences in search on a mobile device
versus online
they're just a sneak preview
most mobile searches are local in nature
and actions take uh take place in a much
shorter time frame which has a lot of
ramifications for our businesses
also mobile and seo uh
different keywords uh
also click to call is becoming uh more
important uh there are some things that
are perceived as unsexy
like a phone call
but we're seeing companies like marchex
and others um
really making it effective
not only to get people to click on a a
link to
uh to fire up a phone call immediately
but also the attribution and the
tracking is becoming uh
very important for us to say okay so
what caused that particular action and
thereby we can uh double down spend more
money and justify the places
where we're expending efforts and
dollars
also paid search
the
list of keywords often are different on
mobile than they are
online as i suggested there's a
different mentality when you're on your
mobile device and you're out there a lot
of a lot more location
uh focused keywords
uh and places like keyword like google's
keyword tool helps us identify the most
common keyword searches
and we're seeing uh google and others uh
really make uh
websites uh and and apps uh
mobile friendly and if they're not they
are
losing ground when it comes to search
results
also mobile and web analytics
obviously important in both both places
they're very similar
but in
mobile we're able to analyze things like
uh device type operating systems uh and
we can take that into account when we're
creating campaigns if we know that most
of our users are say on ios devices or
apple devices versus android or google
devices
also converting on mobile employs the
same concepts as pc uh we'll talk about
how we do that and conversion being the
end goal in both cases
i already mentioned mobile and social
we also want to take into account uh
the
importance of getting uh people to
to share content uh and we're seeing the
advent of user user-generated content
and the importance of
identifying influencers and influencing
those influencers
so who's on mobile as we get close to
wrapping up this introductory uh session
and then get it get it we'll we'll
quickly get into the the specifics as we
move on in the course
well as you know mobile is everywhere
and nearly everyone is using it
uh the penetration of smartphones has
increased uh and this number changes all
the time um suffice it to say uh in the
more developed countries well over 50
percent sometimes even 70 percent or
more uh and
in some of the developing countries
we're even seeing uh
more mobile adoption it first happened
on feature phones
or or less sophisticated phones and is
now uh there are even smartphones that
are so affordable that
they're being put in the hands of those
who even couldn't you wouldn't think
could have afforded it in years past
what are people doing on mobile devices
well just think of what you do on your
phone and
what your friends and family do we're
texting we're sharing pictures
we're browsing the web we're scanning
codes we're clicking on ads
and we're doing things uh more and more
in augmented reality and and such
phenomenons as pokemon go
have now entered our lives uh where what
we're doing is we're taking
the uh the imaginary world and bringing
it to the mobile device and fascinating
people
how young are people uh when they're
using mobile devices
well just going to any restaurant or
looking on any plane or any airport
the very young are using mobile devices
i know
my nieces at one point were sending text
messages at a rate you couldn't believe
the statistics showed over 3000 text
messages a month
and many young users this isn't even
ingest don't even know that you can make
a voice phone call they use their mobile
devices in entirely different ways than
you or i might
how old uh we're seeing uh more adoption
from users in their 60s 70s and 80s i
have an 87 year old mother-in-law who
is
very active on both an ipad
and a tablet uh
or an iphone and a tablet her ipad
she
is playing games she's sharing photos
she's uh
playing angry birds
she's
streaming music
all sorts of things
and why
does she among other
older people do that well mobile devices
have become
more intuitive
it's easy to stay
in contact with loved ones my my
mother-in-law and my wife live 1500
miles from each other but they're able
to stay in more contact than ever before
and the costs as i mentioned of these
devices and the
then the the data and the
the price of making phone calls has
dramatically gone down
so what are they finding uh their users
uh are accessing all sorts of types of
information and you can instantly get uh
answers to questions uh you can get
information that becomes more
personalized and all aspects of these
phones uh are
becoming personalized how they ring
uh the apps that you have on there etc
now i started out by talking about
mobile users expectations now we've come
to the point and not just those of us
who are uh you know in the industry
are expecting brands to perform on
mobile devices these are things like
having fast loaded loading uh web pages
having uh
content that's current uh having uh
content that renders properly on uh one
specific mobile device and we're seeing
uh these uh
rewards and punishments we're seeing
consumers rewarding those brands that
are providing great experiences and
conversely they are
not only abandoning but in a lot of
cases they're telling their friends
they're broadcasting it out on social
networks and it's really become a
problem for brands
probably self-inflicted because by these
days you what you really need to do is
to meet and exceed those expectations
and then users are expecting responses
24 7 which has impacts on customer
service uh impacts how we
react on social networks there's now an
expectation if somebody complains about
something that happens on a flight
or in a restaurant they're expecting
responses in no time
so how do you stay abreast of these ever
changing
technologies well you really have to and
i would encourage you even if you are
looking at mobile stats that are six
months old you need to be even more
current than that
uh looking at uh at the evolution from
future phones to smartphones to tablets
to a word that i hate uh and predicted
would not uh catch on but uh the word
phablet which is a combination phone and
tablet we'll get into different device
types in just a bit uh but these are
tweeners it's kind of the uh combination
of uh the best of a phone versus the
larger size and best of a tablet
but you also don't want to get ahead of
the technology i i've seen some
marketers get into trouble because they
fall in love with something that's shiny
and it really doesn't have
the the legs to succeed in the long term
and even in the short term it takes a
long time to get adoption
when it comes to mobile marketing
measurement we're going to talk a lot
about the things that we could measure
some examples engagement opt-ins clicks
downloads the number of scans
the number of page views and ultimately
the last mile or sales
but mobile measurement isn't nearly as
accurate as web measurement although
we're getting better
but i would argue that a lot of reasons
why dollars aren't following the time
spent in mobile has to do with
attribution and measurement
so there are feverish attempts for us to
get better at that
so as we wrap it up and
get ready to launch into the more
specific individual sections let me give
you a few key takeaways
first one mobile marketing is really no
longer a nice to have and this isn't
spoken by somebody who makes his money
by being in the mobile world this really
is being driven by
by mobile users and their expectations
the adoption of mobile activities is
accelerating and likely so should your
mobile initiatives
how much should you spend on mobile
really has to do with consumer insights
understanding what your customers
do where they are what they're
interested in
and then as i just mentioned be careful
not to chase shiny objects many products
and services
uh we'll see limited use or will fade
away
despite catching on with the so-called
influencers at places like south by
southwest
so that's it i appreciate you listening
to this introduction i'm excited to get
into more detail with you and thanks for
listening
[Music]
hey want to become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learn channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here